on the face the music
for a lot of gears five you might feel
like you're playing another game
straight out of the original trilogy's
locust war much of the game from the gun
played to the story feels like past
Gears of War Games the coalition has
definitely put a lot of emphasis on the
core cover shooting elements of Gears
that have always been strong in
franchise but Gears five also adds a lot
of new ideas to the series and all of
them are useful evolutions that
strengthen its core aspects on the
campaign side the coalition has worked
in some structural changes that open up
how you fight and the encounters you'll
get into you'll still spend a lot of the
game hunkering down and cover and
popping up to score headshots but for
the first time you have more options in
battle and more chances to move around
and use your different combat
capabilities the way you fight is
altered most by Jack the franchise's
r2d2 like robot who follows you around
opening doors and hacking computers Jack
now has a skill tree of abilities you
unlock as you play and can use during
combat they allow you to do things like
turn invisible to sneak up on enemies or
stun and freeze enemies to force them
out of cover
[Music]
you'll spend a lot of time amping up
Jack's abilities with resources you find
in the game which is one of several ways
that Gears of War 5 provides you the
opportunity to adjust the game to the
way you want to play it the middle
portion of Gears 5 also contains two big
open world type areas of first for Gears
of War these areas are littered with
small locations to explore and side
quests to complete all of which are like
mini versions of the larger Gears levels
and encounters you're used to seeing you
can wander these areas at your leisure
and they usually come with a waiting
ambush possibly a bit of progression on
a side story maybe a lore drop and an
item to improve Jack's abilities the
locations are fun short diversions in
their own right and the more you explore
the more powerful Jack becomes which is
a pretty good incentive to cruise around
and see what's waiting for you out in
the wilderness you'll also see new kinds
of battles in Gears 5 you won't always
just run into swarm soldiers spoiling
for a fight for instance sometimes you
might catch them unawares giving you a
chance to set up ambushes or even take
out a few or all of them with stealth
the more open structure of the game
means there are more chances to think
about how you want to approach fights
and more opportunities to change up the
way you deal with your hulking foes the
open portions also provide some of Gears
fives best writing as they give the
characters lots of time to just hang out
and talk most of Gears 5 focuses on Kate
the new protagonist and one of the new
characters introduced in Gears of War 4
as she searches for answers about her
heritage Gears war ended with the
implication that Kate has a connection
to the locust and a big chunk of the
game as her exploring the questions that
implication raises but the best parts of
it all are the many conversations
between Kate and her Delta Squad mates
which do a lot to flesh out their
characters you get closer to the
characters in Gears 5 thanks to these
conversations it's like going on a road
trip with Delta Squad and the game is
great at showing their deep friendships
through dialogue
unfortunately the rest of the story
campaign doesn't hold up as well as its
small character moments the second of
the games for acts is all about finding
answers for Kate but a lot of those plot
lines get wrapped up or pushed aside by
the middle of the game much of the rest
just concerns the fight against the
swarm threat without advancing the
overall story or the character beats
beyond trying to restore the gears super
weapon the hammer of dawn add to that
fact that a lot of Gears fives story
feels like it's revisiting old territory
and everything feels basically like it
did back during the original gears
trilogy the story ends somewhat abruptly
in Gears 5 and most of the interesting
conflicts and character moments get
swept aside to make room for more
flights with big monsters but the
additions that Gears 5 makes to the core
formula all feel like thoughtful
advancements for the Gears of War
identity despite many being commonplace
in the shooter market that goes for
multiplayer as well on the competitive
side the coalition doesn't alter much
about how Gears plays you're still
dropping in to cover dancing around
other players with shotguns and trying
to control power weapons the maps are
all divided symmetrically with
tactically advantageous high ground and
lower tighter areas where power weapons
are nestled instead of changing combat
gives 5 bolsters the experience with
depth the game uses ideas common to live
service titles and they all help flesh
out multiplayer to make playing with
friends feel more involved than just a
series of matches there are progression
systems that lay you advance your
character to unlucky weapons and
cosmetic items and multiplayer provides
a lot of different modes to work through
whether you want some interesting twists
with match types like dodgeball or more
traditional ranked play with team
deathmatch there's something for you
where the live service influence is most
apparent is in the co-operative modes
the wave-based horde mode is back with
some tweaks to push you to specialize
more on your team instead of just having
a squad role as in Gears of War 4 you
now have particular characters who all
have special perks and ultimate
abilities like you'd expect to see in a
hero shooter the same is true in the new
escape mode which has you rushing out of
a swarm hive while you flee from deadly
gas with only whatever limited items you
can scrounge up to help you fight your
way to freedom in both cases you'll pick
a character with a particular playstyle
and specific upgrades you can earn by
playing and those additions help to vary
Gears 5s gameplay and encouraged
the characters don't play all that
differently from one another and you'll
still spend a lot of time behind
chest-high walls but the specialization
options are an enticing reward for the
time you put into each of the games
modes and help make you feel like your
characters are improving alongside your
skills the changes give you
opportunities to play the game a little
differently than you have through the
last five entries in the series you can
even play as Jack in a pure support role
co-op modes also have a ton of
progression systems you'll rank up your
characters unlock new skill cards to
give them better perks and abilities and
even work through seasonal content and
fortnight like battle past pathways it
also should be noted there are cosmetic
items you can purchase through
microtransactions but the Coalition has
said all seasonal content for horde mode
will be free
here's wife doesn't straight from what
has made the gear series strong
throughout the franchise and especially
in its campaign it might be a little too
mired in the past but with so many new
additions big and small this is a
meaningful step forward for the series
everything the coalition adds to the
gears formula helps to make gears deeper
and more open to a variety of play
styles and approaches whether it's the
campaign or co-op competitive or quick
play there's an option for you in Gears
five and the new ideas it brings to the
series are all good reasons for fans to
return